foreign
you know we're tightening up their
formation accelerating now they're above
10 000 feet you can accelerate above 250
300 knots and so they're accelerating
probably 350 closing in the formation
and then the lead just sees something Go
Hard by his aircraft and what he
described was a dark gray or Black Cube
inside of a instead of a clear sphere at
this point we've been seeing and talking
about them enough where he's just like I
was hit one of those effing things we
all knew what he was talking about there
is no real mechanism to report this uh
both from a a military perspective as
well as a commercial perspective and it
happened multiple times right there were
multiple sightings of the similar type
of variety from different Pilots yep
today we'll be talking about the most
advanced stem subjects imaginable from
fighter jet technology to planetary
orbits to the theory of relativity the
best way to learn about these
fascinating subjects doesn't cost
thousands of dollars or take years and
years of schooling it's actually free
and easy brilliant is a great way to
learn the fundamentals of engineering
data science analysis probability and
statistics and everyday technology plus
you can even take an in-depth course
about quantum mechanics from our good
friend Sabina hasenfelder it's a fresh
and new perspective on learning Advanced
topics take a quick quiz when you first
sign in and you'll be matched with
content that fits your skill level and
interest whether you're a complete Noob
or you're ready to write programs for a
quantum computer Brilliance guided
lessons let you explore Concepts at your
own pace if you get stuck there are
helpful hints and step-by-step solutions
to get you back on track science and
Analysis skills are only getting more in
demand which is why I love their new
data analysis fundamentals course it
gives you a step by step approach to
learning everything you need to know to
get started in this exciting field
within a few quick lessons you'll get to
analyze real data and draw conclusions
from it the kind of analysis that forms
the backbone for a lot of my research
and even my content to try everything
brilliant has to offer for free for a
full 30 days visit brilliant.org Dr
Brian Keating that's brilliant.org Dr
b-r-i-a-n-k-e-a-t-i-n-g or just click on
the link in the description the first
200 of you will get 20 off of
brilliant's annual premium subscription
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic
yours truly
Dr Brian Keating alive on YouTube at
least with uh with my new friend Ryan
Graves Lieutenant Ryan Graves former
Lieutenant you're no longer serving in
the active duty you're here in San Diego
and I wanted to let you introduce
yourself to the to the into the
impossible family you're a fan favorite
we won't have you on for a long time and
thanks to my buddy REO we were able to
get you so welcome thanks for having me
here way a quick introduction my name is
Ryan Graves
um I joined the Navy out of college I
went to school in uh central
Massachusetts joined the Navy uh while I
was in training I actually met already
here we can talk more about that a
little bit we believe you invited me on
here today because I've become somewhat
of a public spokesperson on the the
issue of UAP now because we were seeing
these objects flying around
so so yeah that's that's a start I've
engaged this topic with a few
organizations we can talk about that a
bit later so I'm still engaged in the
topic yeah happy happy to be here and
try to answer any questions I can yeah
and just uh to recapitulate a friend
Arielle Arielle can you give your
background and uh your second appearance
on the internet law school podcast after
meeting with uh Professor Lee for his
book The Art of clear thinking a bad
favorite uh tell us about yourself grew
up in New Jersey joined the Navy shortly
after college and went through flight
training with Ryan and Meridian then we
kind of split paths I went uh West Coast
I think you went East and then I ended
up at the at a squadron on the east
coast and we were on the same carrier so
we did a lot of our workups and training
together and then uh deployed both of us
made about half the deployment then we
both figured out what got you into
Aviation why did you want to do that you
went to Worcester Polytech you're an
engineer Brainiac nerd uh probably
growing up as a kid what made you want
to fly high performance fighter jets
except for the fact that it's every
little boy's dream because it's a high
performance fighter jet
so you know it wasn't something I I did
dream about as a child it wasn't
something I was exposed to I didn't have
any you know Pilots or a crew in um in
my family you know I grew up in a very
rural small town so it wasn't something
I was necessarily exposed to on a
regular basis externally as well
but you know I've always been very
interested in technology and all the
things that come with it advancement new
understanding scientific discovery and
for me jet aircraft at least that that
is almost was a personification of that
you know Cutting Edge technology that's
where so much effort was put into place
and that was a place where I could go
and I could take in all those
experiences all that technology you know
all that operational capability right
and just kind of test myself not only
intellectually but as a part of a team
as you know someone that has to interact
with his hands as well as his mind uh
potentially so it just seemed like a
great challenge I didn't know where it
would end I had you know perhaps some
dreams of being able to offshoot and
that so do the astronaut thing uh didn't
have that opportunity but I just saw
that that would hopefully
give me enough experience to be able to
go out and do something fascinating the
world after that what about you I don't
think I ever really understood how you
got tied up and left Princeton and went
into uh went in to serve your country
but what was it what was it about the
Navy in particular I mean David Sparkle
proved to me I was not going to become a
an astrophysicist
um great teacher but uh no I realized I
wasn't great at the theoretical I kind
of maxed out at quantum physics and
decided afterwards to to go into the
Navy when I had always been fascinated
with the Apollo program and I kind of
dreams of eventually becoming a NASA
astronaut it also been kind of pan out
that way to include the more I thought
about space and not you know topic for
another day but it takes a huge toll on
the human body and uh I like being
physical on Earth and like eating good
food and drinking good wine and I want
to climb all mountains
tonight at my house well it's a great
girl to have here so Ryan what brings
you to San Diego you were or one of the
co-founders of a very important
organization so people know I'm a I'm a
pilot but not like these uh American
Heroes real life American Heroes I fly
little you know assassins around but I'm
very interested in aviation we're going
to geek out we're going to nerd out on
astronomy physics and aviations fair
warning we're going to throw in some Ai
and maybe some a-l-i-e-n-s we'll see
about that what brings you to San Diego
Ryan it's so great to have you yeah so I
came into San Diego this week because
the American Institute of Aeronautics
and astronautics for the aiaa as I'll
refer to it a chair committee there
called the UAP or unidentified anomalous
phenomenon integration and Outreach
committee it's a it's a full committee
within the aiaa
voted to that status within the
Institute and that is an integration
committee essentially our charge is to
be able to bring together experts within
that committee uh that have a you know a
wide variety of capabilities and be able
to interface both in our in our
technical activities there within the
subcommittee but also to reach out
across all the uh what they call
technical committees that comprise the
majority of the aiaa and be able to
integrate those technical expertise spin
up teams with particular capabilities or
expertise as needed and so that
organization is having their Aviation
2023 conference which is a lot largest
professional conference for everything
in the air for space and these are you
know Engineers from NASA from historic
Community from you know your large
defense corporations and there's a bunch
of papers that are presented there and
as a committee we participate in that we
had eight papers presented on the UAP
topic during this conference uh four of
them were in person and I present one of
those papers it was on potential
reporting mechanisms for UAP with an
existing Aviation safety Frameworks and
then we had four more in the virtual
session as well so that's what brought
me and we just finished that up here
today is Friday so I'm really happy I
could finish it up with you and I should
also mention your host of the merge
podcast which I very much enjoy it's got
much higher production values than we're
sporting down here at the uh or just a
public university we're not like you you
private citizens out there so I think
one of the things that's most
interesting to me is as an aviation geek
as an aviation nerd is if you were to
say to an average individual or maybe a
commercial pilot a lot of commercial
pilots listen to this uh podcast is
unsure they listen to yours and they
were to see something like what what is
your first step I mean what what do
people do and it could be I'm even on
the ground witnessing some sort of
phenomena but in particular in the air
just take it from that perspective I'm
flying along the coast of California not
far from warning area off the coast of
Catalina I see something what do I do
well you do what you should always do as
a pilot which is Ava navigate and
communicate you shouldn't necessarily
let yourself be distracted by what
you're seeing at this point in the game
right you don't know what this object is
it's probably more likely just a balloon
or a UAV or something of that nature and
so the idea here is if you see something
that's unidentified that you should now
you know go deviate from your course to
go inspector or something like that
right so that's not what's being
communicated here you should be a
professional pilot if you do observe it
and you believe it could be a threat uh
to other air traffic the proper
procedure would be to reach out to your
air traffic controller and see if that
traffic is known and if not you'd like
to give them a position where it is so
they can warn other traffic about it one
thing I've been hearing from talking
with commercial pilots is that it's
essentially what's been happening right
now is that they'll see something either
at their altitude or in the vicinity of
their altitude other aircraft are seeing
it as well and they're calling up the
ATC and they're all kind of confirming
it that is there that they don't know
what it is and they can visually see it
but there's nothing else really to do at
that point so that's part of the problem
of trying to resolve is that there is no
real mechanism to report this uh both
from a a military perspective as well as
a commercial perspective on the military
perspective at this point to see you we
didn't really have the ability to report
unknown objects in any way that would
have got resolved it was simply we had
the Navy Aviation safety reporting
mechanisms and those are you know not an
investigatory type uh of system reports
yeah so you know it's data collection
after the fact so there really was
nothing and if there was represented you
know potentially adversarial platforms
that was ultimately my fear at the time
was that these could have potentially
been some type of platform they're
spying on us and that's something I've
been communicating a bit on I'm getting
off track here so I'll jump back on the
commercial side what should the pilots
do right now in the far in the far the
Federal Aviation or regulations it
strucks uh air crude
they would like to report one of these
they don't require in any way they
essentially suggest that the the air
crew or the witness could go report that
to any number of UFO Reporting centers
that are out in the general public none
of which are well funded or you know
consistent with each other so more or
less information just gets scattered out
and so that's one of the issues that I'm
working to resolve from a procedural
point with the AIA to be able to make
those recommendations but also with the
other organization I started Americans
for safe Aerospace where we can provide
general education and education on
Capitol Hill to be able to push for
those procedures be able to push for
that you know potentially mandatory
reporting so that Pilots don't feel like
they can't bring that information
forward to ATC in the ultimate I mean
there's a stigma on Aviation you know
you do something there's a positive
deviation the air traffic controllers
here's a phone number to call you know
what you're supposed to write down right
after you had some incident you know is
there a sense that like Pilots are not
reporting because they're going to get
on some list with you know Will Will
Smith's going to come up and do some
clicking to them or or that the FAA is
going to pull their ticket they can't
fly anymore on the commercial side yeah
items about that I don't think it's uh
anything uh you know Men In Black
nefarious but guys just generally don't
want to be associated with it but they
don't want the answer for it uh they'd
rather keep their head down and you know
I say that from the context of the
people that have been calling me for the
past you know eight months or more
that's what they're reporting and when
they first reached out to me you know
some of the stories where guys didn't
even want to call it out to HEC because
they didn't want their call side
associated with that report essentially
so that's where the State of Affairs was
of course it's not evenly spread but I
hear that's better now people are
calling it out more but it was
disappointing to see that during the
NASA independent study team public
meeting that the fa representative
communicated they wasn't even aware of
any procedures for Pilots to report on
yes
right yeah they seem to be good at you
know kind of punishing pilots and and if
the FAA is out there please do not you
know pull my ticket Ariel we talked over
lunch not too long ago about you know
events things you saw when you were in
combat or in training you're flying for
Hornet also by the way we were both
single seat Pilots it was about single
seat aircraft or would you guys double I
was single seed uh Ryan flew two seaters
you told me once and maybe you could
tell the story about your encounter with
a UAP at the time
okay can you actually actually no no I
uh in both cases it was observable for
me so I didn't have any anything uh too
crazy I one time in the whiskey areas
off the coast of Virginia we did pick up
a lot of little like scatter and uh one
I was able to to lock onto this and it
ended up I did a right to write with a
balloon there was another time in the
Persian Gulf and this was more worrisome
because I've come off the carrier I pick
up a contact going real slow uh not
getting called out from from uh air
traffic on at the boat lock him up uh I
have a 9x missile which all has another
semester on it and that actually gets
tone which tells me there's something
there I end up doing uh right to right
with a Iranian drone yeah you're
squaring off so basically it would just
kind of fluke right by it yeah so it was
an Iranian drone that was orbiting near
the near the carrier you know dangerous
from a standpoint of one we should be
aware of that it's there which the boat
may have been it was just more warning
Pilots hey you know and I you know I
remember reading in Donald rumsfeld's
biography of all places that you know he
said once that if uh President Bush
wanted to kill somebody it took about 17
different phone calls and you know
telegrams and encrypted you know data
sources before that person would meet
his uh untimely his or her we should be
inclusive a lot a lot of uh you know
worrisome women out there right
um what about that if you saw this you
identify it as as some threat from a
from a hostile Nation do you have
authorization you have tone you know I
mean you said that means by the way we
should we should although you and I are
Aviation errors and Ryan is as well what
is lock on what kind of sensor
technology are we talking about these
are radar sensors or FLIR what are they
exactly the radar usually is the first
sensor you're going to use uh that's
kind of your broadest that's going to
pick up the most everything else starts
to to zero in so in that case I was
coming off the boat and we have to do
checks on our our system so that's why I
use the 9x
it looks for heat sources you know even
at that point my my aircraft's safe
there's no way for me to shoot this
missile like man I have no intention to
do that to broader on your question we
would have to have I mean There Are
Rules of Engagement that are very clear
that dictate how you can employ your
weapon systems and with it being a
peacetime scenario unless that drone
fired upon me or was looking to be a
threat to U.S forces there's nothing I
would really legally be able to do and
then we're hamstrung pretty tightly with
the Roe but it also allows you to keep
keep yourself safe but
you know unfortunately we're not in in
hostilities at that point or fortunately
we're not in hostility so right oh well
yeah not in the Eastern State Board it's
a little different people don't quite
understand but we're not really in an
operational mode when we're operating
with training so we we never almost
carry live ordinance out there that
would be a big exception so that would
take like you said probably 17 phone
calls at least to make that happen that
became an issue actually 911 was when
they were looking to go get the other
airplanes we had a lot of fighter jets
on the East Coast but you know we never
never even thought to to have them uh
weaponized and armed so you know you had
Fighter Pods that were told that they
might have to go after aircraft and
they're trying to think through how
they're going to potentially take out a
threat aircraft without any weapon
systems on board so there's people
asking in the audience uh by the way you
can ask questions in the live chat down
below or on Twitter
uh currently 186 um YouTube and a lot
more kind of tuning in through Twitter I
believe uh so you mentioned this whiskey
air what is that one of the whiskey
areas that like where we're gonna drink
some of this Glenn live it that I got
special made what is a whiskey area what
does that mean what take it sure we call
it Whiskey on a map you'd just see it as
w w stands for warning area so warning
area uh 72. uh I'm sure there's a 73 and
a 71 somewhere but so that's generally
you know north to south but generally
the airspace is divvied up in the blocks
and their warning areas essentially and
I could be slightly wrong here so
correct me if I'm wrong but uh they're
essentially warning uh inbound
International traffic is what that's for
so as military operators we're out there
playing because it's unused airspace
it's not unique to us other people can
theoretically Transit it although they
would get called out yeah that's that's
essentially just where we train yeah
it's a MOA off the water so military
operating area which same thing it
diverts IFR instrument traffic which is
commercial mostly commercial airliners
diverts you around those areas that we
can play but legally speaking a guy in a
Cessna fawn FR can go right through the
middle of it and it happens and you know
that we get called hey there's a you
know 172 transiting the Moa 10 000 feet
and right we have to stop our stuff
which can be pretty expensive with
thirty thousand dollars per hour or 20
to 30 000 per hour and sometimes you
would use the I mean you're not going to
shoot on them but you're going to use
them for training where you're going to
might lock in and assess that or
something like that I'll just say your
Raiders almost always out there paying
stuff so like you do lock up commercial
air traffic stuff like that but there's
no like effect that's occurring on the
aircraft and even if we didn't
specifically lock someone that energy is
getting out there and paying them
anyways and so these are microwaves of
centimeter wavelength Radars and then
you've got FLIR and and so forth do the
missiles themselves have an optical
sensor are they pure heat seeking a pure
infrared or can you see the missile ion
anyway in the cockpit display other
heads up or regular display you can
physically look out and see the sensor
but can you see from its perspective you
see like an infrared image no no but you
can see where the center is looking so
the information will be on like my visor
ever so show essentially where it's
located there's a mode where I could
basically walk that to my cursor if you
will so that I can you know select stuff
you can see how far away it is and okay
so there's an area out here and near
Catalina Island called the restricted
Romeo 2519 and it was a site of the
so-called the Tic Tac encounter we we
don't have commander fraver on I'd love
to love to meet him someday and talk to
him someday but that also occurred in a
restricted area on our military which is
not necessarily purely military the way
a warning area might be but it is used
for you know purposes for training
purposes obviously they had a carrier or
something out there right I would
suggest it I think it is actually just a
warning area right it's not a it's not a
restricted that term means not very
specific
restricted is usually a means you're
operating some sort of like weapons test
as an earlier where it's a highly
sensitive area so off the coast there
could be restricted if there's Naval
gunfire or something but other than that
the point I'm trying to make is you know
this was another area it's a special
using internet yeah so you know I was
talking recently with a with a colleague
but he was in the military intelligence
field but he was talking about you know
the the preponderance of events of
anomalies that seem to occur near
Military traffic Area 51 is a huge you
know Groom Lake Edwards Air Force Base
these two areas you guys are talking
about or we're talking about is there
anything you know to be said about that
like from the perspective of Aviation
safety at least like just avoid those
areas or could it be at some suggest you
know people are either there's
technology from an adversary would like
to go to those areas too and get a sneak
peek at an F-18 right um or 35. so what
do you make of that is there anything
you know to this theory that of course
things are going to happen in strange
ways you know to call me when it happens
over Times Square kind of reaction that
I often get well my first go-to here is
who's probably observation bias involved
so we're seeing them there because we
have uh the sensors to actually be able
to see now with that I also don't think
you know this issue is going to be one
particular thing uh for a while and you
know we're going to find adversarial
platforms we're going to find drones and
things of that age we're going to find
trash that's great and that's helpful to
our national security and we have
systems in place to mitigate that but
there's a category that you know we're
ignoring essentially and that that data
set and that's that's what I find we
need to work now and so you know I think
we're going to have adversarial
platforms around those bases so there's
going to probably be uptick in you know
unexplained or or um
unidentified objects around those bases
maybe just because they're adversarial
platforms but I think there's an
observation bias as well and to your
point earlier you know you're talking
about kind of the Beijing probability of
of you know a commercial pilot versus
military pilot seeing these and what
that can affect it's such a small bubble
that a commercial pilot can see so you
know when you talk about sightings from
fighter jets you know you have the
potential to get highly correlated data
across multiple sensors you know
different types as well as you know
different geographical locations of the
data reception if you will or the
sourcing ground-based sensors or
eyewitness statements things of that
nature you don't have that luxury
necessarily and so we would expect to
have much better data around those
systems and then on the commercial side
there you know the visibility range
where you could see you know one to four
meter object is pretty small depending
on the conditions it's certainly within
10 nautical miles we'll just use that
number and if you think about you know
the volume inside that 10 10 Mile bubble
compared to you know what you get with
an Acer radar it's pretty easy to see
why we get more sightings than that this
is more overlay there's more data right
yeah and our Radars are way better than
what is an assessment citization or a
747 yeah right for different purposes
right there for eliminating other aerial
threats potentially so we were talking
earlier as well before we started the
the podcast
um about you know this kind of notion
that a lot of times we'll engage with
with people in the military or people
that have claimed to be eyewitnesses
people talk about like oh the data
belongs to us I've had on Avi love who's
coming back to talk about this book
which is excellent book sure to be a
bestseller and obvious that's his best
I'm sure from the Fiji islands where
he's apparently found some anomalous
wires he's found uh some manganes
someone in a live chat correct me but he
found something today he was announced
on his medium page which I get um some
strange metallic composition and we're
going to nerd out about like
potentialities of what could be found so
first of all you've had some contact
with Javi um both students on your
podcast and him as well where does this
kind of Interest take you beyond the
very very important and critical you
know deadly serious literally
implications of of just anything in the
airspace that's not monitored not
tracked where there might be
discouragement to reporting or visceral
reactions to reporting
um bias and so forth but where where
else do your interests lie with regards
to these phenomena
enter ever entertain the fact that they
could be not of this Earth or is that
interesting but it's not like
necessarily what drives your involvement
and oh I supposedly be that question
sure so I mean for me personally
um yeah I I think you know I would be
lying I think most people would be lying
to say like that obviously that
possibility is extremely you know
tantalizing right yeah that's just human
nature I think and you know like you you
talked about earlier that's something
I've actually tried to fight against to
just be as effective and that of focus
as I can so that there's there's no bias
that I'm pushing uh subconsciously
although of course we all are but I'm
doing my best so I try to draw a firm
line in my mind of what I have you know
first-hand experience or data right and
you know of course I can hear that data
from learning and things of that nature
and I like to you know step past that
line and kind of explore where those
extrapolations go a bit I think it's fun
to do but I don't let that affect you
know things on the other side of that
line the things that I know because
that's you know extrapolation is fun so
I do I like okay it's fun stuff like you
know I'm a Sci-Fi fan so all this is
very interesting to me I'm interested in
Cutting Edge technology and where we can
you know do that I want to be able to
support that type of stuff that's all
very interesting to me but I leave that
on the other side of the line so that we
can focus on what's pragmatic which is
data and being able to just bring it in
and talk about it without stigma because
that's where we're at it's very basic
still exactly what are you around what's
your what's your uh interest in this
Beyond say the very critical life saving
potentiality and I should say you're
involved with the aviation in space to
this day as well so where where do your
interests take you in this in this
domain still flying so uh clearly you
know anything that's in the air is of
interest and a threat a Potential Threat
right you want to keep me and my
passengers as safe as possible but um no
I think there's a you know there's the
good science means looking into anything
you know people in the 1950s and 60s
we're seeing Sprites lightning strikes
that go up into the outer towards outer
space and you know I'm not very smart on
the astrophy the physics of of these but
so you know I'm sure I'm going to say
something wrong here but for a while the
scientific Community the community at
large kind of played that off and in the
end there that is a real phenomenon and
eventually I think it was in the 80s I
think the space shuttle astronauts could
actually confirm that this was happening
and then you start looking and now we're
you know that's a that's an aspect of
our of our world and our system
understand and didn't know about really
until until people started observing and
starting to look into it so you know
it's just pushing the scientific
envelope requires curiosity about
anything that you don't you can't you
don't know or don't understand yeah I
mean I always say you know there's no
one more than a physicist or an
astronomer who would like to make
contact with something Beyond this realm
because I think it would shortcut first
of all guarantee employment you know
fall employment or astrophysicist
forever right if we ramped up our budget
when there was just the Soviet Union you
know 10 of the area of the land mass of
Earth that you know Quinn toppled our
budget for years to come how much more
so would it be for uh discovering alien
technology but that's a risk we have to
guard against because I think there's a
lot of propensity to want to leave stuff
and there's even the memes about you
know I want to believe I don't want to
believe in gravity you know I've got
evidence of gravity we can we can do
experiments we can replicate stuff and I
think you know sometimes we we do have
to guard upon it and I think there might
be a little bit of a stigma Orion that
you speak to about you know when people
let's say you report something there's
almost a supposition on the on the part
of the person who's hearing that report
that oh well he wants to believe that
does that enter into it where there is
this confirmation bias or is it like
hell no I was like this could kill this
could blow up my plane or this could be
an enemy of the United States and I'm a
patriot I signed up to defend my country
at what level do you react negatively
someone says oh of course he just wants
to believe in this things in science
fiction like we all do but he's using
you know the fact that he's seen things
or witnessed things you know to bolster
that how do you guard against them
because that's common claim that people
make right no I mean no frankly I
haven't heard people claim that um but
uh if they are um so be it but um you
know for me I try to keep myself on the
line of what I've observed and what I've
directly talked to my colleagues and
what they've seen then today I'm just
doing my best to record on that and to
improve the the Aerospace safety around
it right and so that's where my all my
effort is so if people want to look at
my track record to justify my behavior
then they're going to see see nothing
but me focusing Aviation safety on this
topic because for me that's the most
pragmatic way that I can reach back and
you know be able to help the people that
I used to fly with it's really that's
really where all this started do you
mind if I ask you uh some personal
question that would be you don't you
don't have to answer it we could delete
it later but I mean it seems like this
is very altruistic right so how are you
gonna you know you have a family now
right I mean how is this going to
translate I mean everyone needs to
provide for the material safety of the
family and security I'm just curious
like and you don't have to answer if you
don't want to but like is there any way
that that this can be remunerated uh you
know in some fashion or another it
seemed very altruistic in other words
and and yeah I don't think you've
already done enough for your country
that you know one wouldn't say oh now
it's your time to give back and it's
kind of you shouldn't be doing it for
free well you know I think that what's
most important this conversation is
building up a self-sustaining industry
if you will around this right so I don't
like the traditional pack that
Chromebook UFO Community has on this
where if anyone makes a dollar then
there of that nature I think we need to
bring people into this conversation so
that we can run experiments we can build
sensors we can influence on Capitol so
we can do all the things that every
other industry in this country does so I
don't like that General logic because it
relegates this conversation to the Hobby
and there is real work to be done you
know I hope the generation may come from
the podcast but I'm not you know not
making anything in terms of like uh go
ahead do you want to speak about other
efforts that you're undergoing on that
front or we could talk a little bit more
about that in the future a little bit
later on so one of the well let's just
do a nice pose so there's a number of
things I'm doing there's Americans for
safe Aerospace that's a non-profit and
you know ideally that would generate a
small amount of income for me but
primarily all the money there's more
user polling and research and things of
that nature for the AI double A that's a
complete volunteer organization so
nothing there and I think you understand
the podcast game and how lucrative that
can be oh yeah that's paid for this
season but aluminum foil replica of the
James Webb Space tells me but what I
would like to do what I would like to do
with merge with the podcast is take that
conversation and develop it with the
help of the listeners be able to take
the ideas we're getting take the uh the
expertise that we've brought to the
table and raise money around that and
say hey here's some ideas we've
identified them and can we now support
that ecosystem either by you know
providing potentially grants for
experiments or or money to fund new
sensor technology things of that nature
so I want to be able to grow and expand
this ecosystem I think that's really the
way to do it yeah yeah that's that was
excellent It's kind of the model Avi
lobe is used I mean with with more kind
of uh contacts by use of the he employs
the h-bomb you know drops Harvard on
people and all of a sudden billionaires
show up at his doorstep as he's told me
on his uh so he's right now in a cruise
in the South Seas near Fiji Excavating
where the first Interstellar meteorite
the first one that they have documented
uh there's been probably millions of
them over in Cosmic history so this
leader of the spectrometer company
Bruckner Spectrum dropped a couple mil
and said let's go out there so but the
citizen science model you actually have
way more people that are interested in
aviation and fly and so forth everyone
who's on a commercial plane can could be
a witness right so is that kind of the
the effort as well citizen science or
citizen I don't know what you'd call it
but yeah it's our way to incorporate the
general public I mean you can speak to
the audience but what can they do to
assist them especially participate in it
as as general public members yeah so
there's two ways first way whenever I
engage in this topic I do so two ways
one I try to engage with stakeholders
within government within DOD be able to
provide the answers to the most pricing
questions they have right because again
I'm trying to support National Security
here in aviation safety and that's the
best way to do it I correctly interfaced
with solving the problems that they have
but we're also engaging in the
conversation uh on the Civil side as
well one of the activities that we're
planning at the aiaa is actually a small
sensor package that can be distributed
to schools and the general public and
we're looking to tie that in with a data
provider service provider that would
look to donate that compute time to be
able to run algorithms that we're
generating at the AI double A provide
that wider plethora of data it's about
trying to find patterns in that data so
the more that we have the more we can
kind of suss out some of those details
and that's a similar I think process
that can be done with eyewitness reports
and non-censor reports I think the the
bar is higher we need more data so that
we could pull out those Trends but I
think there is valid information to be
pulled out of there and mass right on
average as we look at the data
how did you react this week in the last
week There's Been reports from this Air
Force I guess Commander Captain uh for
Colonel Lieutenant Colonel maybe um I
forget but anyway grush uh his name you
know that there's kind of expose that
there have been uh you know claims of of
not only alien craft but but even alien
bodies and so forth I personally find it
hard to to accept and I don't want you
to comment on him directly but but this
notion that not only do we have to
accept that there are these phenomena
but these phenomena are actually aliens
and these are actually from distant
technology Etc it seems like an
insurmountable barrier to get over right
although in the past few years thanks in
some small part to pass guest on the
podcast Tom Delong and others who have
made this you know front page news in
New York Times it seems like there's an
arms race between people that want to
believe and people that want to
disbelieve I was just curious how did
you react I mean it's in your literal
space no pun intended how did that
affect you just as a as a citizen and
being someone very active in the space
yeah great question you know it's
shocking for me too to hear hear that
information come out but you know I I
think of it that I have to remind people
that this didn't necessarily come out of
nowhere they didn't necessarily utilize
The Whistleblower protections that were
ordered in the 2023 National Defense
authorization act but it was in response
to the ndaa legislation which
essentially called for whistleblowers
and provided protections and so in that
language it very specifically you know
called out crash for people programs
that'll use a lot of very aggressive
language we're not used to seeing in
ndaas
um and so you know he is someone that
has a lot of experience and has had a
lot of access and he's making these
claims but like everyone else this
information that he's now taken before
Congress big claims require big evidence
and theoretically they have that
evidence in their possession and now
it's in congress's hand to validate that
information and then share what can be
shared I think with the general public
right yarn kind of had a bit of a
discussion the other day just on what
the difficulty of kind of keeping the
conspiracy like that I'm a bit of a
universal skeptic so I agree big big
claims would require some pretty big
data um obviously there's credibility
from someone within the intelligence
Community who had a lot of ties I
reserve uh judgment until I pay some
more agency more yeah people say there's
a Trope that you know eyewitness
evidence isn't worth it you know they do
this thing with a gorilla bouncing a
basketball and there's a bunch of people
and oh they didn't notice the gorilla
came through and they're counting the
number of people so but but it is a form
of evidence but the the question and we
briefly touched upon this but I think
it's valuable to talk about what
constitutes data like when we hear this
word like the data belongs to Americans
and this is you know this is public
information and this should be released
or the evidence have you ever Miss as I
said once I had on David Chalmers who's
a professor of you know studies
cognitive science and philosophy at New
York University and I had him on the
podcast and I said David you know he's
from Australia I said uh you know me not
asking you to define the hard problem of
Consciousness would be like me having AC
DC from your Homeland to Australia not
played Back In Black I think Ryan you're
back in Black uh I I would love for you
to recount if you were willing to what
you witnessed because we can talk about
garage and he can talk about you know
what he was told by other eyewitnesses
but we have someone who has had a you
know Arielle had an encounter he talked
about what that was it was said can you
would you mind like detailing this these
encounters that you have discussed
elsewhere but I think my audience is the
best in the known universe uh so it it
would be remiss if I didn't ask you to
recount back in uh five to seven years
ago I guess oh gosh not long huh
this time this month it's now been uh
eight years since I landed on a boat
really yeah wow yeah we're gonna have
the into the possible aircraft carrier
take you guys out yeah
my experience was we came back from
deployment I got sent to the USS
Enterprise and you finished a little bit
after I think you joined I joined right
after right now we came back so I joined
them on the point and we came back and
when we came back to what happens is
you'll start upgrading systems or
repairing things yada yada we were
upgrading we were a rare Lot number I
think it's called where essentially we
were engineered or manufactured so that
we could be upgraded later it was a
small amount of aircraft that were
upgradable essentially he's a Super
Hornet superherent yeah and so we
started upgrading our Raiders when we
got back which was awesome because of my
like level three check arrives can be so
much easier with this radar than than
with the older ones but you have a land
more precisely they are precise I have
to do as much like finger work you know
and things of that nature Automation and
cockpit resource the other one is a
mechanically scanned it literally the
radar is moving and you have to if you
don't have everything set properly it uh
you can actually completely there it
required a lot more pilot uh
that's demanding resource right so they
had upgraded the block that you were
yeah and it took a while it took um
maybe like three or four or five months
because you know it's one at a time and
they take it in and took like a good
week to do one aircraft but anyways long
story short we were flying with our
older radar we weren't seeing anything
really to know and then we upgrade our
Radars and then started detecting
objects in our areas there's two
conversations here there's and that's
the one first conversation I'm having is
what my real-time experience was there's
some things I've learned since then and
I'm gonna hold those but so just to be
clear that um I'm just kind of talking
about my interactions first person
Observer and what that was we you know
other folks in the Squadron were seeing
stuff and it was we weren't talking
about that much unless it was an
incident we had to move areas or if we
want to look for them so it's just kind
of chatter in the ready room eventually
we started correlating that for
essentially seeing on other sensors so
okay we were thinking these were radar
errors you know because you get false
track hits on our older Radars at least
was my assumption that this was probably
a false track of some type until we
started getting uh returns at least on
our camera flare system 18 foot here at
least for me at the time was like okay
well if we're seeing these on the flear
now being correlated we have to assume
these physical objects that we have to
we have to were there any people seeing
starting in drama are there any people
singing in a radar is kind of like an
experimental control like it was only on
the new radar sets it's a it's a pretty
big upgrade from 73 to 79. so resolution
power what what exactly was the nature
of the upgrade to the red I mean you can
be as geeky as you want one is
mechanically scanned the others uh
scanned array
um Power is probably higher I mean just
generally everything but the same size
ditches or panels or you know roughly
the same resolution or would you get
like you could see now the tail number
which you probably can't like air-to-air
you're just scanning and it just shows
you tracks it's not you're not
developing a picture off of the reader
but you said you did see it on flare so
now you've got two different wavelengths
that are separated by 10 to the seventh
order of magnitude you know roughly in
wavelength so yeah so go ahead
anecdotally after the fact again this is
like later knowledge I had spoke with
other Pilots interviewed one of my
podcasts and I talked with others who
got vectored into traffic that was
interesting which place stationary
objects and that's the majority of what
we were seeing but yeah stationary
ground tracker okay
um
and uh
he was asked to go and go check out the
object essentially this was over by the
Dare the range so he went off and
intercepted apg-73 radar he essentially
had the quarter moon kind of Zoom it in
zoom in the radar put more energy onto a
smaller piece of the sky in order to
break it up but they didn't he did break
it out and as he approached pretty close
apparently it it just started off and
that was that so I thought that was
interesting because it kind of showed
that there was a connection perhaps
between kind of the more resolution or
the more radar energy also just on that
spot with you know being able to see it
better what was interesting too when we
talked about that was there's this thing
called the target aspect indicator which
is like people that comes off of it one
thing I've said is that I was
identifying these objects by how it was
inconsistent the target aspect indicator
and detected these he said the same
thing except instead of having it moved
inconsistently it didn't move at all so
when the object went away from him it
actually went away backwards
telescope to kind of Target aspect so
what would that indicate if you're
trying
I would expect to see on my on my radar
if we were kind of looking down Circle
oh yeah there we go
so yeah if aircraft's going like this
it's finding this direction then the
target aspect indicator basically
pointing in the direction the vehicle is
going right and so
when I the target aspect didn't move and
it darted away but this was the aircraft
that had it essentially the stationary
object and then it just started flying
backwards and flew away that way
um so not to say it actually flew
backwards but the target aspect
indicator never changed Direction it was
as if it was kind of walking backwards
after
yeah more or less yeah okay so I would
expect that's due to limitations
doesn't represent the kinematics of the
vehicle so you saw it on the there's a
sensor on the on the missile or whatever
or this is unclear on the job so the jet
hasn't missed and then then the missiles
would have it but you said you weren't
necessarily armed at that time or were
you we have our sensors on our training
missiles that we fly with so we can get
tone on these objects as it's called
although we can't actually launch on it
you know we would get tone on them they
would get picked up by the way that the
metallic artist having some radar return
it's giving you some there's a heat
signal enough of a heat signature for
the missile to get track and okay and
the 9x if we're carrying the cadm which
is the the fake 9x those are those
sensors are pretty pretty solid
so that's that's like our new upgrade
the 9x yeah right those are the ones I
shot down the Chinese balloon with right
a couple weeks in 100 months ago uh
which we maybe will get to if we have
time what are your thoughts about that
again so yeah flying enthusiac let's
keep going down that yeah so so here we
are now it's on the Fleer and then
naturally people are like let's go see
what they are uh myself included and you
know what that looks like is we try to
merge with objects so here it is and we
typically want to come below it and look
up on it and you can see below the
aircraft and ideally we want to go as
well I like you have no idea well we do
yeah I mean first time no like we didn't
you know haven't seen I don't know how
big it is really or yeah it's gonna move
or whatever if they're doing it there
but um we would come up to it and our
radar would be locked on my
to see it it I couldn't see anything so
that was kind of the status quo for a
while you know at least as far as I knew
at the time where people were trying to
fly up to it and not seeing it now I
don't know if that means that they
didn't all represent physical objects or
if there was other you know trickery
going on to prevent a visual ID but that
was a status quo for a while until we
had a near midair with one of the
objects so how did that come down
because that seems like they'd have a
lot of incentive to want to avoid that
and also could you get in trouble for
just going out there or could you
justify it rationalize as part of the
training like you could inspect it yeah
yeah we can certainly have the agency to
go do that at least initially one of our
most common missions like in the Persian
Gulf is just see search if you go find
any you know anything you see out there
it's yeah you could go in and you can go
and inspect this kind of type of thing
and it's visual can constitute like the
highest form because like a lot of these
could occur at night and by the way did
any of them occur at night or yeah they
were out there at night uh we weren't
added to my knowledge and no one was
flying by them anymore
so talk about the near counter or
whatever yeah so it was two aircraft
with four people total only the first
aircraft Elite aircraft saw it they were
flying to go do a mission I don't know
what it was out in the areas two of them
flying side by side they went the way it
works is there's a single point that's
the entrance to the working areas at a
very particular altitude and there were
leaves a thousand feet below that more
vice versa I forget but either way they
you know were tightening up their
formation accelerating now they're above
10 000 feet you can accelerate above 250
300 knots and so they're accelerating
probably 350 closing in the formation
and then the lead just to see something
Go Hard by his aircraft and what he
described was a dark gray or Black Cube
inside of a instead of a clear sphere
that was stationary with respect to him
or so he couldn't tell now I'm gonna go
back a little bit because we had
described it wasn't perfectly accurate I
said it flew past them right but that
was just a relative yeah view so it's
our understanding that it was stationary
at that location and that they flew
through it but of course it appeared
that way to them plus their separation
we tipped to wingtip pretty tight I've
been using about you know 100 to 150
feet as an average because they were
probably tightening up to get in there
and stuff so you don't know the exact
distance but button there okay so so go
on so then they yeah so the object you
know it's hard to you know really
objectively think is that they're going
by like that especially with a surprise
and all that so confidence in the data
is you know somewhat low here I'll say
but you know he described it he thought
it came closer to his aircraft and so he
described it as like five to fifteen
feet in diameter that was what he could
kind of glean from you know seeing it
Zip by his aircraft at such close
distance if you're hard to tell the size
of object unless you know what it is so
yeah I mean that was that was
essentially it he they turned around
they canceled the flight after that they
weren't confident that they're you know
hit or essentially to clear their nose
they were in the ready room with all
their gear on when they came back and at
this point we've been seeing and talking
about them enough where he's just like I
don't get one of those effing things we
all knew what he was talking about then
we were kind of obligated because it was
so close that we had to file a safety
report and kind of the chit chat in a
squadron with the commanding officer and
whatnot was that you know okay more UFO
UAP I mean I didn't know that term UAP I
didn't think it was I mean it was a term
but it wasn't something that we were but
you know we thought perhaps these were
some type of classified program that
maybe you know had
inadvertently operated where they
shouldn't have or whatever maybe we
could kind of
get a message to them that they were now
you know this was going to lead to a
mishap if they didn't take care of it
and get their you know their stuff in
order and it happened multiple times
right there were multiple sightings of
the similar type of variety from
different Pilots yep okay when we
initially filed that safety report part
of the conversation was actually like
well [__] you know we've been talking
about Steve
uh you already did this YouTube stuff
sorry sorry my Flawless rating oh no no
people have cursed many times all right
cursing like a sailor is not a thing oh
yeah
yeah so yeah multiple people or multiple
encounters I always said yeah so so
what's that called well crap we've been
seeing these things uh so much we can't
just have this one teacher or you know
so like we actually filed several of
them at that same time to kind of showed
that this was a problem which is a you
know that's an error I think right we
just couldn't have taken that long to
import these but did I just go into the
void I mean is this you know kind of
like
Aviation safety officer and there are
different reporting mechanisms for
different emergencies of the
the hazard that's been identified
um you know potential mid-airs that are
of an unknown cause that are you know
have the potential to reoccur eventually
that made their way into the no time so
that every time people were flying there
was okay it's a notice to Airmen it's
something that
yeah so um for submitting an address
like that ultimately it's kind of gonna
get Mass blasted out and like it's
someone's gonna read the email and then
file it away uh but that's basically it
remember what happened to the Ark of the
Covenant so I mean but isn't that the
support I mean maybe it's a blessing in
disguise because this might have
encouraged you to start your new mission
on the civilian side right if it was
like the government was taking this very
serious it is disappointing I have to
say as a taxpayer I don't have the
courage that you guys have to you know I
mean I would have liked to but I
couldn't fit into the flight suits you
guys are pretty Diesel and we I do want
to talk I always like to talk with
extreme High performers for my audience
I got a lot of young men out there they
want to be like you guys so we'll talk
about that at the end I wasn't in the
jet you know you guys were flying on my
behalf and so forth but like this is a
lot of freaking you know money and blood
and treasure potentially going down the
drain you know I'm kind of pissed off as
a as a citizen you know what the hell am
I paying for you know taxes for if you
they're not going to be protected how
much money goes into a training a Naval
aviator in a high performance aircraft
access to level three probably yeah yeah
so millions and and that's trivial
compared to the cost of losing a single
person right it's quite Frank likely a
shame that that you know and this is
multiple government presidential
Administration can't blame it on the
current one right I'm disappointed as a
taxpayer right
I didn't realize it was still a problem
until 2017 the New York Times article
came out and I recognized the video or
the image that was on that because that
was taken by a squadron Man of Mine
right that's a so-called gimbal yeah I
was like holy smokes this is this is
this is not being resolved whatsoever
there's still an issue and so I reached
back to some buddies and just asked you
know what was going on and it was still
an issue and
and that's kind of that's that's that
was my decision at this point I haven't
even really thought of it frankly I
hadn't thought of it after I left until
I saw that and then I was like holy
smokes this is this is not going to get
resolved within the normal systems and
that's kind of what led me to pass them
all today I mean it would be
disappointing and I mean you can comment
on the story but you know that's the
only way to get attention to things that
could be extremely dangerous but prosaic
in other words it could be you know
drone or whatever it could be less
Prozac uh like alien technology or
somewhere between like a military
obviously but the only way to get
attention is to whistleblow it seems
like a broken system outside of that or
someone crashes into it and then they
investigate and then it'll become an
issue but that's why we have the safety
data actively look at what the problem
was right so that's that's how we do we
write our procedures in blood we still
think that they're out there now or
whatever these objects were or they're
still being claimed to be cited and what
about the commercial traffic okay so
it's a warning area so it's not like
likely that Southwest is going to be
operating and then necessarily but it
could I mean the warning areas can be
inactive and then IFR traffic can get
routed through it so so we have
questions in the audience and please
leave a couple questions we're going to
go for a little bit longer then we're
gonna go have a nice show but we're
going to introduce uh Ryan to shabbat if
he hasn't had it already did you call
him at the brismila the circumstances
we'll talk about that later okay don't
worry about that can Ryan go into
Malik's gimbal analysis I don't know
Lakers but talk about the gimbal if
you're comfortable with it and what what
is a gimbal what does it have to do with
this event and what are some
explanations both you know on both kind
of sides of the fence so the term gimbal
was given to a video that was released
by a Navy the name of the video has no
consequence to anything objective it's
just someone in the Navy apparently okay
with that name I would really actually
kind of curious who probably a good
question so you know let's not over
index on that particular name but you
know a gimbal is an object typically a
spin in a self you know self-corrects
and stabilizes itself based off of the
centrifical or station I know there's
one that's always the wrong one right
yeah Richard Feynman said if you know
the difference you're a high school
physics teacher
that's right the only High School
physics
um so it's yeah it's a platform that's
gyro stabilized for pointing platforms
they're all over the place and
Technology usually hit it but um this
object that appeared in the video
appeared appeared to almost act like a
gimbal because it it seemed to be you
know wider in the middle I guess and you
know I don't know the justification
frankly right so I'm not even going to
try to explain you know name it but uh
you kind of get the sense of oh this
kind of looks like a gimbal because it's
moving around in strange ways and the
story behind that is we were out off the
coast of Jacksonville Florida uh we were
doing our I believe it was just a workup
event which is
you go through two workups before
getting deployed uh certified to go
deploy the first is Tista so that's just
you as an air Wing operating with the
carrier then you go through comp2x which
is you as a battle group operating
together so it's just okay yeah okay so
that's a little more tactical so yeah
great great question
um I cannot remember what the acronym
stands for it all right so anyways we
were out there and that's what we did
we're operating off the aircraft area
we're doing training and honestly it's
more dangerous and more intense than a
combat operations at least our modern
operations so it's pretty intense um
they they do push us and stretch our you
know capabilities and it's graded as
well uh but anyways one day we were
going to do an aired Air flight we go
out together do the mission and then as
you come back one by one as you run out
of fuel you you don't just go back to
the boat and land you slow down to a
non-tactical AirSpeed a Max endurance
AirSpeed and you basically get out of
the way and just go hang out and you
just we call it hanging out in the
blades waiting for the landing to open
up at the boat but we don't have enough
fuel to just bring it up and go fly
tactical so we have no choice but to
just hang out wait and we're lord of the
ring for your landing spot right like
the gate give the gate to open up for a
civilian Southwest right
so it was during this time that this
worker came back they detected a number
of objects on their radar or noticed it
on their situational awareness page they
noticed it to the east of the carrier
initially they thought that it was
perhaps some type of penetration test
because during this they actually sent
out red air aircraft or simulated
fighters from the shore to test a
carrier's reaction essentially and so if
we're doing some Mission you know you
might be tasked with knocking it off
even to go a training Mission knock it
off the go go see these guys essentially
go try to intercept them so that's
essentially what they did they saw these
objects they thought perhaps that's what
it was it was strange because they were
the east of the boat were already a few
hundred miles out the coast so you know
these kefirs and whatnot that fly it's
uh how they would have got out there
without a seeing them so that's the red
squad or red what'd you call it red red
air yeah there's adversaries that are
paying commercial or you know civilian
aircrafting yeah sometimes right yeah
yeah and so they went to essentially
inspect these objects they call more or
less Stern converted it which
essentially they approached it and tried
to get behind it and started flying up
to it initially you know my memory
served it was somewhere in the six to
eight nautical miles that they had got
within this object I actually later had
the pilot came up to my house to hang
out I'm still friends you know an ass I
was like correct my memory how close
were you guys you know and he's like ooh
it was four to six miles you know
um so even closer than I originally
thought they got about four or six miles
from it it was dark and you know my
understanding is they peeled off at that
point and headed back to the boat and so
that was the gimbal object you see there
there were other objects as well I
learned about this when I watched the
debrief in the in the Civic space when
they played their tapes and there was
four to six objects I call them smaller
objects four six smaller objects that
were kind of past the gimbal object that
were flying into formation and their
target aspect indicator resembled the
scattering that the ones on the East
Coast
were displaying so for me that led me to
assume that they were perhaps the same
objects that we had seen but they don't
necessarily have evidence of that the
gimbal object we'd never seen anything
like that before that was unique
so a question from the audience here
from somebody named four get it 25 which
I was going to name my third child Fork
at it what kind of reduction in speed or
need for thrust would going against the
wind characteristics look like a la the
gimbal video in other words what kind of
let's say it was a you know just a
whatever minute drone or what have you
so sexacopter as I like to say what
would it be you know what would it
requires like hurricane Force you know
stability or you know could how could
you stabilize it what kind of velocities
relative velocities and so forth work
well
I'm not 100 sure I understand the
question I think you're saying if we
were to assume it was a standard drone
well presumably some altitude wind in
there
odds I think is what they were so yeah
so you need substantial thrusting so
they're asking you to stabilize it in
the wind so it's stable with respect to
a ground track it would need to have
exactly the negative of that velocity
you'd have to know how big the aircraft
is like there's a lot of different
factors it wasn't stationary though yeah
but the ones earlier oh so the get the
given what's that stationary correct
against the backdrop yeah okay so that's
why I understand yeah so it actually
wasn't stationary it's turning or moving
it's going against the wind which was
going 120 knots and so back to the
original question which is what I think
about that um thing essentially what was
done I think there was like some open
source work that was done by Midwest and
others that created a model for the
kinematics of the Gimbal and the net
that were derived from what can be seen
in the fluid display itself that model
the only variable essentially that's an
unknown is the distance from the jet to
the unknown object if you you use
witness data
to fix that object at about 46 miles
away from the aircraft then the
kinematics and trajectory of the
aircraft essentially look like a j-hope
where so this is vertical right here so
we're coming and is climbing and
essentially doing a great hook if you
take that model and you extend that out
to 30 miles or so it's a straight and
level trajectory flight profile and so
if you the most logical assumption that
people make if they
they'll include the pilot testimony is
that that's really the most logical path
for it to be the straight level path at
a large distance if you include the
pilot testimony what you arrive at is
that J hook maneuver which is
interesting because that is essentially
What was seen on the situational
awareness page where the object was
proceeding One Direction and this is a
God's eye view that we see on this so
the object appeared to just stop and go
back in the other direction it could
have just done a very tight turn that
that model represents so the model's
interesting because again it was kind of
an open source effort it wasn't one
particular person's it's just whether
you want to include that testimony
that's my understanding of it you know I
haven't
delved into the model that much
you know getting back to this notion of
military organizations and by the way
it's not just navies air for all the
services maybe even the space force now
dealing with these phenomena in some way
or another NASA is as well we mentioned
David Sparkle and Colleen on Simon's
observatories president Simons
Foundation he's leading his NASA panel
my colleague Charlie Wright and
Professor Shelley Ryan here is involved
an optical setting looking for
extraterrestrial intelligence using
laser signals for receiving laser
signals from uh potential
extraterrestrial civilization that you
guys are both out of the out of the
service but it just seems kind of
callous it seems like they are not
taking this seriously and and you know I
guess the question is would you advise a
young you know Ryan you know go back in
time like go back into the military Ari
let's start with the art
you say like you know an organization
that's treating its employees in this in
this sense just from a you know a
business you know recruiting perspective
HR perspective on LinkedIn here's this
entity we we routinely have events that
could cause your untimely demise and we
invite you to submit an email on this
forum on SurveyMonkey and that's about
it would you advise a younger re to go
into the Navy or any military service
let's say the Air Force those guys you
know they're not
there's a lot I have a lot of gripes
with certain things within the military
uh that being said though I mean I got
one of the most unique experiences I
think it developed me in you know I was
a nerdy kid growing up in Princeton from
academic family Ivory Tower you know I
traveled a lot but it gave me a
different a very different world view
and perspective and confident and the
military paid me to fly 80 million
dollar Jets so you know you have to
taper like military lifestyle stuff uh a
lot of time away deployments do you
think they frequently you know I think
we are burning our force and that's
that's something that I it that's a
larger question but you know I think
we're we're burning our people and a lot
of people are leaving the military
lifestyle is extremely hard we're
operating at wartime conditions for 20
20 20 plus years and it doesn't seem to
let off and and that is taxing our
forest and I feel for you know
especially the the maintainers and the
sailors like they're it's an extremely
hard we're requiring a lot of people
conversely like it is an extremely
unique and amazing experience
so I would caution I would tell anyone
you know if my kid my son wanted to
become a fighter pilot I'd tell them hey
like
you know are you willing to do XYZ are
you willing to get you know have to deal
with these things I wouldn't tell them
not to do it but I just thought I'd give
them the pros and cons you know I think
there's I think they're both so
my urine I think when you do that job
you accept a lot of risk I'm not going
to give you the whole tax statement but
but what we do at aviators is we
mitigate risk and we ex and therefore we
accept it um and that's fine and that's
you know what we sign up to do and
occasionally however you run into
scenarios it could be rare where you are
introduced a risk that has no mitigation
and that I think is a disservice and
that's what we started with in this
conversation I've seen it other times in
the military and it hasn't ended well
but we have to be able to mitigate those
risks appropriately and I think we're
starting to do that with the reporting
processes that are going in place so to
The Wider question you know I would
again probably communicate with my child
very clearly on the risk that they would
be accepting by doing that and I just
hope to God they make a good decision
right because I don't want to tell them
what to do but I want to you know do my
best to give them a wide view of all the
options okay Chris French 83 on Twitter
is asking questions for Ryan please Ryan
so far do you have any pilots who
reported to you seeing the same metallic
spheres in the skies around the world
commercial pilots military Etc are we
being is it the uniquely American
phenomena or yeah I'll answer this
differently which is I'm not saying this
but Dr Sean Kirkpatrick and even in the
last NASA infestation team public
meeting stated that these were being
seen in all operational areas around the
world
okay Pete Venkman asking the sphere and
Cube matches the description of radar
reflectors
what makes these objects spotted by
Graves and Company anomalous and not
simply radar reflection or similar
object
yeah so you know I've had this
conversation many times but here's
here's the here's the problem I describe
various situations of these these
objects and they're stationary or
they're doing extra they're doing why
where things get more anomalous is when
you kind of zoom out you zoom out and
you look at the object temporarily over
time and you say okay it was tank
stationary and then it was you know it
was proceeding at very high speeds and a
holding pattern for a very long period
of time and that that becomes hard to
explain and it's the accumulation of all
those data points over time that kind of
leads us into the well we don't actually
know what it is bucket it doesn't lead
us into a conclusion but it's Crossing
certain things out and just leaving us
with that question mark over our head
still
Scott debunked Scottish debunk one
that's funny sorry to bother can you ask
on certain vector by the way follow Ryan
on Twitter on certain vector and follow
the merge podcast as well as we'll get
into that in just a bit what is the
relationship other than being 10 minutes
apart between the go fast and gimbal
video I talked about gimbal talk about
go fast yeah
well I like that I'll once again suggest
that we were not responsible for the
naming of that video
um but you know this is one I actually
don't have a lot of data on when I went
into the room to watch those tapes uh
after they landed that's not a video
that uh I watched or saw okay I've
spoken with the pilot since then and
they have some they have some questions
about that video as well so
Bro Dog which is not my brother-in-law
Brew dog out there in my Marine car
Recon hoorah and a gym if you're
listening out there I love you brother
has Ryan contacted the senate
subcommittee for Aviation safety
operations and Innovation to raise
awareness of the UAP issue from an
aviator's perspective if not I kind of
suggest for him and say Aerospace to
engage with the Senate subcommittee
chaired by Senator Duckworth it's only a
great idea we're engaged through
American for safe Aerospace
congressional oversight committee as
well as the National Security
subcommittee but the one that was just
mentioned is not one we're engaged we're
also looking at this FAA reauthorization
that's occurring this year is there room
in there for any type of UAP budget at
the FAA considering how they were just
stating how they're having such a hard
problem you know they didn't have the
resources of the tools to actually be
able to to track or or potentially
investigate these occurrences
question from Gaston peer and speaking
out must have drastically influenced his
daily life his worldview his friendships
and I'm assume they're talking about you
not me my favorite subject uh his
worldview family his family life
relationships his military Brothers can
he tell a bit about the time frame in
which the most intense changes took
place for you I I don't know if you're
comfortable asking yet about answering
it I think that's a good one it's a it's
kind of metal ex-friedman style meaning
of life and love Etc you feel
comfortable with that how did it affect
you as a human as a man as a father as a
husband if at all yeah you know it's one
of those things where it's it's a
conversation that
was a slow boil
for me at least personally I can't speak
for everyone and so I feel like I'm very
much inside of the conversation still in
a way like we have there's no conclusion
here that I've reached you know we have
a lot of work to do and so
in a way I'm not even in a position to
kind of retroactively look back and you
know assess that because I still feel
like I'm in that slow boil but there has
been a lot of changes I mean you know I
wasn't expecting to
engage in the subject of course I wasn't
expecting to speak on you know news that
was it was all stuff that was outside
the scope of my experience I don't know
if I'm doing a good job of this question
but I don't know I think they want you
to go a little personal I mean you're
the steely-eyed kind of guy and you've
got this you know whatever you guys both
you guys you guys have this Persona and
I I respect you tremendously and and I
have great fondness for you and if my
sons or daughters wanted to do what you
guys do I'd be I'd Point them to you for
sage advice but I know I've seen things
or whatever and and had experiences none
of which are potentially at the level of
this but I mean you know if you're
religious it could be a miracle I mean
when you encounter something like that
it has to affect you as a man I guess
you know I guess that's the nature of
the question I'm curious too I'm glad
Gaskin asked it so I can raise my my uh
you know comment in the form of his
question but you know to what extent
does I mean the implications of what
you're involved with are both from
saving lives protecting individuals and
securing our country but even beyond
that you you have to realize that these
are these are huge implications how can
that not change a human being on a
personal level I think that's what the
I've tried not to let it change me to
the point uh and we talked to us a
little bit earlier right where we have a
line of objective data and inclusions
and extrapolation on the other side of
it you know I've I've I've tried to not
let things to this point affect me
because I truly you know I at my core I
need more data to be able to make a
conclusion about this I'm not driven
with a conclusion in mind so so for me
personally I've tried not to let you I'm
sure absolutely has right I'm not I'm
not trying to be uh but you should ask
your wife it's not like that yeah
exactly yeah we get her on the podcast
but you know I never feel like I had
this big come to Jesus moment where my
like my worldview changed I feel like
I'm I'm I'm hesitant to engage in that
type of self-reflection because there's
just so much other work to do before we
can get there
not the answer I know people want to
hear but yeah I know okay that's how
I've tried to you know there are a lot
of I think I mean
as a fighter you have a lot of
instances in your career that yeah are
going to change you to you know from
scaring yourself to death multiple
different times throughout your course
where you're you know a second away from
going into the ground or Landing just
you know landing on a pitching deck at
night and having to go around four times
because the conditions are terrible and
yeah there are a lot of things that you
know shape you so
uh next comment comes from a listener's
name I'll tell you in a second I was
asking um why am I so hot uh it's very
strange uh generic gay guy is the name
Brian why are you so hot so what made
you shave your head the way my mama made
me I guess yes I assume they're asking
about it oh yeah he is available quality
is available ladies out there uh just
submit uh I'm his uh I'm his agent uh I
wanna I wanna address the shaving head
question first before we move on yeah
every few years for a while I used to do
in the Navy a little bit but the
difference I think this time is that I'm
continuing to be shave it so you know
I'll let that speak for itself
uh one of my friends past guest Brett
Weinstein others have said you should
assume it's a psyop let's dig into that
just for fun speculation what is the
purpose of Assad we hear that all the
time so what does it mean first of all I
think it means and you guys correct me
if I'm wrong you know that it's it's
something done by some forced undermine
and separate and atomize the coherence
integrity and so forth of another of
another entity of an adversary yeah I
like to think you know there's almost no
better way you could engineer the
atomization the polarization of an
already fragmented country you know
start introducing things that just
completely bizarre we can't explain them
we don't understand them uh they could
be military they could be adversaries to
what level you know should do you agree
with the statement made by Brett you
know uh assume it's a sign up unless
proven otherwise and what scenarios
could you envision a sign up playing out
like what would be the motivation who
would be behind it let me start with you
on that and then
itself
I mean people have been experiencing
phenomenon in aviation I I haven't but
you know like even
you hear about early astronauts seeing
things in outer space that they couldn't
you know so the the fact that they're
they're things that need to be looking
into I don't think would be that aspect
I know the psyop I've heard a little bit
I think I read some articles a couple
years ago that I think goes more on to
them trying to create a external threat
that would impose the One World
Government is sort of the generally the
situation that I've heard that as yes
could also be something within say the
Navy right it could be we want to test
the Loyalty of Ryan or this whistle
whistleblower someone in the Air Force
is concerned I'm just making this up by
the way if Russia's out there but you
know they want to test they have some
suspicions maybe he these leaked
information about whatever whatever
again preface I'm not accusing but I'm
just saying there could be it could be
within it doesn't have to be China right
it could be something they're trying to
smoke out something suss out something
that could be a motivation that's not
even a foreign entity and or it could be
stress testing we do these SWOT analyzes
on telescopes and how resilient Army to
a virus that takes down you know our
supply chains of Chile why not to psyop
so I think I think the first thing you
said is the fact that it would be
entirely legal for that to happen for us
to Target psyops on you know U.S
citizens uh would be highly highly legal
and I think would likely irreparably
damage the trust between the federal
government and its citizens as you
should frankly if that was the case so
um you know it sounds like perhaps this
question is more directed towards the
recent uh statements made by brush and
his activities so yeah I mean to the
point yeah sure assume it's a psyop and
even if he's not involved right he could
be receiving data from 10 people and all
10 million people are you know part of
this IOP and are fighting it with bad
information and so to that point let's
wait and see what type of evidence is
presented to Congress and you know allow
them to vet that information because
ultimately that's the only thing that's
gonna sway anyone's mind so we're just
going to continue process right because
the process has been established so like
I think there is a way to do this now so
whether you think it's a psi-op or not
let's just let this play out
now you're the Secretary of Defense in a
major I just promoted you I'll ask you
the same
um as soon again you're the president
coming up
um uh so yes now you have all these
resources at your disposal you could
commission astronomers around the world
to all train their telescopes all the
what what's on your dream list to
increase the data content quantity
quality Precision Calibration what sorts
of things could my colleagues in
astronomy do I want to criticize Avi
when he came on the podcast absolutely
he has a vested interest and then some
of the stuff he's doing but you know it
is true there were no civilian you know
efforts to look at the sky but now let's
take it let's just say by Fiat you are
avoid Austin or whatever what would you
do what what kind of supplementary
information data Etc quality quantity
calibration would you be most beneficial
to you and your mission
so I uh I'm not gonna answer it the way
you want but we can go into some of that
more stuff after but to start I would
say sadly uh it's not a technological
Pro it's a stigma problem uh and so if I
was you know in that position I would be
pushing in the middle management ranks
in order to standardize reporting on
this across all the services I think
there's buying at the top there's buy-in
from operators but there's you know
essentially
middle rank officers that are you know
at that operational level that are
either going to make or break that
system and if they don't have buying on
it there's also ways that you can
Implement that into training into the
actual Aviation uh training pipeline
things of that nature
um so stigma reduction of that will
increase pilot reporting uh to enable
new data uh that will allow this
conversation to be a normal scientific
Endeavor you know in our capitalistic
Market we can have you know an industry
around this we can advance the sensors
we can potentially get government
funding for uh these different companies
to be able to expand and provide
solutions to the government so reducing
stigma I think just allows this whole
conversation to open up but then when
you start looking no now to more
directly answer your question I think
there are some you know there's some
signatures that have been spoken about
by Dr John Kirkpatrick that are
potential targets of opportunity uh and
the one to three gigahertz range and
I've got the higher range but there's
some other things that we're doing
looking at such as what are some perhaps
passive detection capabilities that we
could utilize and so I think there's
some very interesting ways we can
leverage existing transmit Technologies
I'll say very Loosely to be able to
passively identify disturbances in
electromagnetic radiation things of that
nature and so being able to look at
password systems I think are huge and
there's a number of options all the way
uh I won't get into the details but
there's a number of passive systems that
could be used and then of course on the
active side I think anywhere from
wideband hyperspectral bass sensors from
space are an ideal you know kind of
low-hanging fruit that could be attacked
and then you know
more fun conversation is one of the
coolest things you could potentially do
with gravity detection things of that
nature are we able to uh specifically
adjust our radar system so that we can
work predictably see these things can we
then take that data and combine it all
and and apply machine learning to it so
we can perhaps get proactive detection
of these objects to be able to cue our
sensors one of the big problems I
believe is going to be latency due to
the relative High velocities that we're
seeing in the the low amount of time
that these occur just happen over that
if we do want to have follow-up
investigation we're going to have to
have probably some predictive uh
analysis or predictive capability in
order to QR sensors and so Advanced
algorithms more data anything that's
going to be able to increase the amount
of data through sensors is going to
ultimately add to the conversation so
yeah or down to the benefit and safety
of no variation in space in America and
yeah and we can get we can get data from
that too if we're able to proactively uh
interrogate and skew and that right then
we can start being you know more
intelligent we can start being more
defined with what we're actually looking
for instead of being reactionary and
predict rather than just so you know
it's like I always call the ring
doorbell fallacy you know you buy these
ring doorbell monitors they allow you to
see who stole your package no and like
what time exactly times down to the
micro saying all right what about you as
we wrap up uh today's conversation what
what kind of if you were you know God
more of a god a handsome woman
um
I don't want to play the rank card uh so
what would you do I mean as a scientist
as a physicist trained physicist strong
astrophys what would you want to do to
increase not all Ryan covered the
benefits to you know to Aviation safety
and so on what would you do just as a
speculative maybe uh wild uh speculation
what would you most want to do if you
figure out how to get myself a ride into
space
no I think uh you know just yeah
funneling money to people like Ryan and
others and you know uh
haven't given it much thought so it
can't go too far into that uh gentlemen
as we finish up well first of all I want
to ask uh you to talk a little bit about
the merge podcast how has it affected
you you know in the in the bright lights
and big uh big microphones of being a
podcaster what are you getting out of it
what does it do for you what do you like
about it I I am learning how much I say
filler words uh I'm realizing how
popcorn didn't tell you that loud my
breathing is even yeah even more so uh
and how much I don't like listening to
my own voice very common but what I am
what I am experiencing that's positive
is that we're able to widen this
conversation in a way that is bringing
more people into it in a way that
couldn't be done anyway frankly who's
their dream guests besides the two of us
who's your dream guest on the podcast
he's active duty right now so I can't
say his name okay
if you could talk to the president Bible
or vice president Harris because she
seems to be in charge of like artificial
intelligence which we didn't get into
hopefully when you come back or I come
out to New Hampshire maybe we'll do a
part two that'd be great um if you could
talk to the highest levels of world
government uh what would you tell them I
would just make it clear how pragmatic
this issue is and how commonplace it is
that this isn't necessarily a historical
conversation that happened a long time
ago and we're looking to add to that
context now it's something that is
pragmatic and has potentially real
consequences from uh not only National
Security but Aviation safety if we
looked at Eastern Europe we need to know
who's who in the zoo there and we don't
want to have unknown third-party objects
that are potentially causing misfires or
things of that nature so just let them
know there's very serious National
Security issues and there's a pertinent
and Urgent problem okay
um so Arielle knows this because he was
on last time with a major he was a major
at Hazard League I find an episode up
here down there wherever you want I
always like to ask one or two
existential questions
um I saw how deep you like to go you
know interpersonal things that's that's
uh that's fine but I do want to ask you
the name of this podcast called into the
impossible and it comes from Sir Arthur
C Clarke's one of his many dictums he
has many of these aphorisms one is any
sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from Magic but another
one is the only way of determining the
limits of the possible is to go beyond
them and Venture into the impossible
so I'm going to ask you in the form of
advice to your former self 20 year old
Ryan
not necessarily anything to do with what
you're doing now what advice would you
give him do as you've done to give him
the courage to go into the impossible
yeah I just tell them to be bold and
fearless ultimately what held me back I
think and held a lot of people back is
just fear of acceptance and if you're
always uh driving yourself towards a
mean that's where you're going to end up
fantastic Ari any questions for your
buddy
thank you for coming back on the show
many times you're a fan favorite people
follow uh Ryan on Twitter on certain
Vector we love Vector calculus around
here don't we and as merge podcast you
find that on YouTube and on all audio
channels got some great interviews and
some ones coming up you told me about in
the Canon you'll have to subscribe to
find out about that and I really want to
thank you and I want to thank both of
you guys you guys are heroes of mine
you're the best of what America has to
offer and I really do Salute Your
courage and and learn everything you
know you and I get together a lot and
it's great and I learned a lot from you
today and I hope uh we'll be able to do
a part two sometime so for now we're
gonna go out and have some uh some sweet
kosher wine everybody out there shabbat
shalom if you celebrate if not uh Happy
uh Fourth of July and we'll see you guys
for a little while uh thank you for your
service as well and uh it's been a blast
thanks guys okay let's go have some
holla
thank you
foreign